[Music]
brexit is of course a tricky issue to
navigate but the fact is once we leave
the European Union we will have extra
freedom for manoeuvre and I think one of
the most exciting things that's
happening now in Britain is the new
generation that's coming through and I
think this is a different generation
from ones we've seen before I describe
them as heir B and being goober riding
deliverer eating freedom fighters and I
see some people in the audience shaking
their heads but we see opinion polling
shows that younger people are more like
to set up businesses so there's been an
85 percent increase in 18 to 24
year-olds setting up businesses in the
last four years they're more likely to
have a side hustle alongside the normal
work they're doing whether it's running
a YouTube channel whether it's renting
out a bedroom on Airbnb whether it's
running working in the economy in
different ways and I think it is because
that generation has grown up with more
freedom than previous generations more
information at their fingertips and more
capability and I don't think it's
surprising that that generation believe
in lower taxes than older people
generally do they're also more
interested in things like public service
reform so I think that shows that there
are people out there who want more
opportunities in British society and I
think that over the next few years we've
got the opportunity to get that energy
use their energy and help Britain become
a more successful economy to get rates
of economic growth up but also to raise
the opportunity of every individual in
this country to help them live their
best life so how do we do that well
first of all the free enterprise economy
is absolutely key to that that is the
thing that gives people the ability to
be able to take control
of their own destiny you don't have
freedom over being able to live your own
life if you can't control your own money
and that's why I think it's so important
that we keep taxes low on people
particularly on those businesses that
are just starting out where people want
to take a risk they want to aspire they
want to do things differently I also
think that we need to make sure the
government is doing less better so I've
been doing a series of spending review
roundtables around the country talking
to people about where they want public
money spent and what people say is they
want money spent on core public services
like the police or education or health
making sure our roads work and I think
that is where we should be focusing our
efforts and too often I mean we have
seen a bit of a creeper creeper plan of
a government where we now have three
hundred and five different quangos and
regulators which cost 2.5 billion and we
see more and more regulations placed on
people's everyday lives and businesses
so is it really the business of
government to be saying to people how
big their pizza should be or what the
minimum price of a glass of wine should
be I would rather the government is
focusing on those core basics they're
going to help people get on in life and
if the ultimate devolution of power is
to the individual which I believe I
believe firmly that we need to empower
people and as people become more capable
more informed they're better placed to
take decisions than the government are
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at AI
TV
you